こんにちははじめ社長です
この度
暑中見舞い申し上げますこの度
皆様に
お願いしたいことが一点
ございます
皆様
この動画をご覧になっていると思われるの
ですがスマホで見られている方
いらっしゃいましたら
僕のチャンネルの
そこのこれをしてみてください僕の
チャンネルに飛ぶと思います
飛んで上の方に行くと
youtube のアプリにはですね
チャンネルアートというチャンネルのこの
ヘッダーみたいな見出しの部分がござい
まして私のチャンネルのヘッダーがですね
え只今 youtube オリジナル
the fake show お前は誰だ
ん
というものに約3年程この youtube
なんと作らせていただいた the
fake show という3年前のもの
約3年前の作品になっております3年前の
作品のまま私のチャンネルアートは時間が
止まったままでございます
ずっとこれずっとこのすごい形相の僕と
びっくりしちゃった僕の顔
いやー4遅く4江差ターサー不具合が付い
さあもう3年前からずっと一緒の
チャンネルアートで今までやってきており
ます肇社長です
変えたい買いたいと思いまして今回この
動画を撮らせて頂いておりますもうでも姉
もチャンネルアートって難しいんですよね
どう作ればいいのか何でもいいやみたいな
を正直この部分なんでもいやとか思いつつ
も実はチャンネル入ったらさあまず目に
とまるどころかだからさん結構大事だなぁ
と思って切っ9支えられずに約3年ほど
経ってしまったんですけども
今回満を持して新しいチャンネルアートに
変えようと思いましてさんネイルアートの
ためだけにきょう撮影してまいりました
なるほどするねやってもこっち私も
ちょっとのが心配それな
[音楽]
偽造薬ライブ
バッハ
アップの後 the いいですね
r 1はっはっは
設置台数
ああああああああああああ
はいというわけで完成したのがこちらで
ございますでも明日かあさってくらいには
これになってると思うんですけども
さみしいですね所持寂しい素材となって
おります結構春拳に撮影してきました僕の
チャンネルのすべてがかかっているような
大事な素材ですからチャンネルアートって
こそじゃないんですよねスマホで見ても
テレビとかで見ても pc てみても
ちゃんと写るようにちょっと細長い形が
いいなっていうことでこれをちょっと行き
ました
[音楽]
これをとってきましたたぶん明日か
あさってには僕のチャンネルアートの生育
相の部分がこれになっていると思うんです
けどもここで皆様にお願いしたいことが
ございます
今のところ
マッスルなんですね後ろがこれをどうにか
どうにが素敵な画像ねしてくれないかその
作業は皆様にお願いしたいと心から思って
いるのでございますよろしくお願いします
私のツイッターにですね先ほどのあの倒れ
ている始めたつを若干が入ってますが若干
レッド肇社長のグリーン学区的背景緑ば
画像の素材を私の twitter に
置いておきますもし
もしお時間がある方または画像を作った
ことがあるよ画像を編集したことがある
よっていう方がもしいらっしゃいましたら
こちらの素材を使って素敵な素敵な
チャンネル後をつくって頂ければ嬉しいな
と思っておりますできたちゃってる朝
ツイッターでつぶやいていただきます
とても助かりまーす魔法の時はここしか
映んない何かてない見たとここまで pc
だとここまで見たい結構保坂ない画像に
なると思うんですけれども本当にそれを私
のチャンネルの一番上に外れていただき
ます作った画像をツイッターで投稿して
くださいハッシュタグはじめシャツを
倒れる足坂肇社長たはれるをつけてその
チャンネルアートつぶやいたらあの僕見
ますんで足場をはじめしゃちょー倒れる者
の調べさせぴーと卓球も朝までそれでもう
これいいなとって扱えばの連絡させて
いただきますあの
便利あのいいのがたくさんあったら
ちょっとか八かなたまに一とするで
しばらくからチャンネル後で遊ぶ子ません
が皆さんで素敵な物を作って頂きたい出
なければ私はじめし相互チャンネルの
チャンネルあとずっとバッシュの肇社長が
寝たままでございます僕には画像のセンス
がありません絶しつ的な画像ちゃんねる後
お待ちしておりますいやーちょっと僕も
なんかなんとなくです自分で作ってみた
けれどもこんな感じとかは結婚姫かと思い
ましたん結構横広なんで本当に難しいと
思うんですけども期間とかないんでもう
極めて暇な方が入ったらぜひ作ってみて
下さい皆様どうかよろしくお願いてしまう
[音楽]
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
ワンワンワンワン1個
おっぱ
おっぱいっ
[音楽]